on est on est on est bientôt au mois de
septembre et l'iPhone 14 les iPhone 14
vont bientôt arriver alors comme chaque
année j'essaye de regarder un petit peu
ce qui va arriver ce qui va se passer
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de choses qui
se présentent beaucoup de rumeurs on
commence à avoir un peu le portrait
robot alors c'est vrai que si on regarde
on l'avait déjà un peu une vision de ce
à quoi pouvait ressembler
potentiellement j'ai bien
potentiellement parce que on rassure
dans l'hypothétique on n'a pas de
confirmation mais ce à quoi pourrait
ressembler potentiellement les iPhone 14
maintenant non c'est quand même beaucoup
plus on a un peu plus de visibilité de
vision sur la fiche technique sur ce qui
pourrait arriver donc aujourd'hui on
fait quoi alors on boit un coup à la
santé à la votre à la vôtre déjà c'est
tellement chaud qu'il faut il faut
s'hydrater l'eau c'est super dans 20 ans
il y en aura plus parce que des gens
dame Jean-Claude à ta santé donc
aujourd'hui on va faire un tour complet
de ce que pourrait être l'iPhone 14 vous
êtes prêt vous êtes accroché vous êtes
chez vous vous avez de l'eau ou autre
chose allez-y on y va c'est parti go
[Musique]
alors on va regarder différents trucs on
va déjà regarder un petit peu le design
on va regarder ce qui vient se présenter
et ce qui est intéressant on va
commencer par regarder ce design là
c'est ce à quoi pourrait ressembler le
line-up des iPhone 14 en 2022 et 2023
bien évidemment alors en fait il y a un
vrai changement l'iPhone mini qui était
un iPhone un peu plus petit que 5,4 % de
mémoire je peux me tromper mais je crois
que c'est à peu près ça petit format il
l'avait sorti avec l'iPhone 12 mini ils
ont continué avec l'iPhone 13 13 mini et
ça n'avait pas été un franc succès
potentiellement cette année il serait
arrêté et on aura un line-up un peu
différent alors pour autant Apple
conserverait quand même quatre iPhone au
catalogue cette année pour avoir plus de
choix j'en sais rien on aurait donc
l'iPhone 14 classique l'iPhone 14 pro
qu'on connaissait déjà au niveau du
modèle Pro modèle normal modèle Pro le
14 pro max donc un iPhone 14 avec un
écran plus grand ça on l'avait déjà vu
arriver depuis deux générations et puis
la nouveauté qui viendrait remplacer
l'iPhone unif à part remplacer mais
prendre la place de l'iPhone mini donc
catalogue d'Apple ça serait un iPhone 14
max ça serait donc un iPhone 14 mais
plus grand donc on aurait donc deux
produits classés par la famille l'iPhone
14 l'iPhone 14 max et l'iPhone 14 pro
iPhone 14 pro max et vous le voyez
directement ce qui semblerait en tout
cas changer c'est l'encoche l'encoche
c'est l'arrivée en 2017 avec l'iPhone 10
et donc elle est restée alors elle s'est
réduite un petit peu une dernière sur
l'iPhone 13 mais pour autant elle
continue à être présente sauf que là si
c'est ce qui est présenté là est avéré
on devrait quand même un vrai changement
qui serait quand même radicalement
important autant en conserverait
l'encoche qu'on a aujourd'hui sur les
iPhone 13 donc avec votre face ID qui
viendrait manger une partie de votre
contenu autant là on viendrait gagner
20% en termes d'affichage c'est à dire
que vous auriez toujours votre caméra
qui serait planqué là et là les capteurs
pour la reconnaissance en trois
dimensions face ID qui serait là donc ça
vient en fait apporter une intégration
un peu meilleur ça évite d'avoir une
partie de l'écran qui est mangé là ça
paraît un peu mieux intégré ça reste
néanmoins visible alors de toute façon
il est évident que la prochaine vraie
grande innovation qu'on aura ici
prochaine grande changement ça sera la
caméra sous l'écran mais on l'a vu la
caméra sous l'écran avec le Samsung
Galaxy Z fold 4 un lieu que le Z fold
III c'est pas mal mais pour l'instant
les techno sont pas suffisamment bonnes
pour que on ait une caméra de bonne
qualité et ça complètement invisible
donc il est évident et connaissant Apple
qui l’intégreront quand ça sera vraiment
extrêmement bien maîtrisé et quand les
technologies seront prêtes à être
totalement invisibles et avec des
caméras de bonne qualité derrière donc
autant dire qu'on n'y est pas encore et
on y sera pas encore dans les années à
venir donc le Paris d'Apple ici c'est de
se dire ok on va venir moduler un petit
peu et au niveau de la gamme pro de
l'iPhone 14 on va venir mettre ce petit
truc là qui va venir changer donc il est
évident que sur l'iPhone 15 qu'on
retrouvera les années suivantes si c'est
vraiment ça qui se fait attention on est
pas vraiment sûr mais si c'est vraiment
ça qui se fait on aura ce système là un
peu partout pour l'instant il y a une
transition qui s'opérerait
potentiellement mais je trouve ça assez
malin alors les dénominations on les a
évoqué comme ça c'est pas dit que ça
s'appellera l'iPhone 14 max 14 pro 14
pro max 14 pro 14 pro max à peu près sûr
que c'était la dénomination qu'on avait
déjà donc on va continuer comme ça car
iPhone 14 c'est sûr aussi maintenant
l'iPhone 14 max bon j'en sais rien à
voir tout en sachant qu'il y a une
rumeur qui fait état d'un potentiel
châssis en titane qu'on retrouverait
peut-être que sur le modèle Pro versus
l'iPhone 14 avoir donc on aurait autre
chose qui arriverait au lieu de l'avoir
de l'alu on pourra avoir du titane on
verra ça plus tard le dos on aura un
design qui serait totalement identique à
ce qu'on a aujourd'hui au niveau de
l'iPhone 13 c'est le 13 pro max on
aurait que deux capteurs sur l'iPhone 14
et l'iPhone 14 max et 3 capteurs sur
l'iPhone pro et l'iPhone pro max bien
évidemment regardez d'ailleurs là ici on
a quelques infos sur le site Apple
track.com on voit ce à quoi ça pourrait
potentiellement ressembler au niveau des
modèles professionnels là le châssis
potentiellement en titane et les caméras
qui seraient potentiellement les mêmes
que ce qu'on a aujourd'hui voyez hop là
quelques petites infos bon ça ça reste
effectivement à voir et à confirmer
d'autres infos voyez ça pourrait
ressembler à ça en termes d'intégration
aussi il y a une autre humeur qui parle
d'un écran ltpo alors le ltpo vous
connaissez je vous en ai déjà parlé dans
d'autres vidéos le LTP permet d'avoir un
taux de rafraîchissement variable ça
vous permet je crois que je suis Apple
on laisse enlever jusqu'à 10 on avait du
10 à 120 Hertz et en fonction de ce que
vous allez regarder vous allez pas avoir
le même nombre d'images par seconde ça
va venir apporter plus de fluidité et
lorsque vous descendez vous gagnez au
niveau de l'autonomie sauf que là on
aurait du ltpo de nouvelles générations
promotion chez Apple et ça permettrait
de descendre jusqu'à un Hertz alors ce
Hertz c'est important un truc plutôt pas
mal c'est du always on display ça veut
dire un affichage permanent sur votre
iPhone aujourd'hui votre iPhone quand ce
qu'il est éteint il est éteint il y a
rien il y a rien qui va s'afficher en
plus là vous auriez une horloge pourquoi
pas des widgets différents trucs
d'afficher ça pourrait être pas mal donc
on descendrait ici on le voit hein 120
Hertz mais jusqu'à un Hertz est-ce que
j'ai l'info qui est écrit ici ils n'ont
pas noté sur ce site là mais ça pourrait
être assez marrant et on voit que c'est
une info qui vous deviendrait de Rohff
young voilà à voir et on est là sur le
site Mac remorse.com qui a quand même
pas mal d'infos qui dans cet article là
accompliait un peu les dernières rumeurs
qu'on va retrouver sur les iPhone 14 et
je vous le dis cette dalle ltpo
descendant jusqu'à 1 Hertz ça va être
aussi hyper intéressant pourquoi et bien
tout simplement pour pouvoir gagner en
autonomie alors on aurait aussi une
nouvelle puce et la puce à 16 bionique
enfin il y a une petite truc là dessus
je vais vous raconter dans quelques
instants vous allez voir c'est pas hyper
hyper évident mais surtout dès lors que
vous descendez le taux de
rafraîchissement le nombre d'images que
vous allez afficher par seconde puisque
vous affichez moins d'image par seconde
et bien vous gagnez en autonomie vous
poussez l'histoire un peu plus loin si
par exemple et ça je vous l'ai dit
également dans mes tests des Samsung
Galaxy Z flip et Z fold 4 lorsque vous
lisez un article sur un journal
quelconque que vous êtes juste en train
de lire vous n'êtes pas en train de
scroller vous descendez sur du une image
par seconde on n'a pas besoin d'en
mettre d'autres donc on va venir pousser
l'autonomie un peu plus loin ton
smartphone au niveau des écrans on
aurait la même taille entre un iPhone 14
un iPhone 14 pro et les max ça sera
exactement la même taille c'est-à-dire
que là on aurait une diagonale de 6,1
pouces qu'on a déjà cette année et là
jusqu'à 6,7 pouces donc pas grand
changement de taille de format pour les
personnes qui veulent vraiment des
grands écrans et un énorme affichage
pour du divertissement et de l'autre
côté on va venir maîtriser un petit peu
plus ça très honnêtement j'ai un iphone
très pro max j'avais déjà un iPhone 12
Pro max c'est gros dans une poche c'est
très gros c'est pas fait pour tout le
monde mais moi j'aime bien en tout cas
je me suis habitué je trouve ça plutôt
pas mal regardez là on nous demande des
images de ce à quoi ça pourrait
ressembler on voit bien les deux
capteurs photos principaux sur le 14 et
14h ils mettent 14 plus mais ça serait
14 Max comme les dénominations on les
connaît pas on vient chercher un peu des
des idées de noms mais j'ai je pense que
si on sort en 14 pro 14 + 14 pro max on
complexifie la gamme et ce dont a besoin
Apple c'est de lisibilité pour le
consommateur pour moi 14 + on l'aurait
pas ça sera effectivement pour les 14
plus mais 14 max ça me paraît quand même
beaucoup plus logique l'appareil voyez
on a des rendus alors c'est des vieilles
images mais ça pourrait potentiellement
ressembler à ça il y a une autre info
alors cette info là elle est assez
intéressante et elle soulève plein de
questions on sait que chaque année Apple
va présenter il va proposer sa nouvelle
plus dans ses nouveaux iPhone cette
année on a la puce à 15 bionique et on
s'attend cette année à retrouver une à
16 bionique ça vient matcher avec le nom
en plus de l'os IOS 15 l'année dernière
iOS 16 qui était présenté au mois de
juin lors de la dame si la conférence
des développeurs d'Apple c'est vraiment
du software ok sauf que là on aurait a
priori un truc c'est à dire
effectivement sur les modèles pro on
aurait bien la A16 la puce à 16 bionique
mais sur les modèles non professionnels
on pourrait garder une A15 bionique et
là ça me parait c'est bizarre parce que
en fait Apple ils ont jamais dit si vous
prenez des smartphones avec des tailles
un peu plus petites on va venir vous
proposer une puce de génération
antérieure donc il ira un peu moins vite
ça parait bizarre après et vu ce qui se
passe en ce moment en période de crise
en période de manque de composants
période de pénurie et ce que l'inflation
vient rajouter un peu de bordel
là-dessus c'est complètement possible
est-ce qu'ils se disent bon ok on a pas
assez de composants pour fabriquer des
puces à Seb bioniques doit faire le
choix de scinder un peu les gammes ça
peut être une explication qui viendrait
un peu justifier expliquer en tout cas
ces rumeurs ce ne sont que des rumeurs
attention une fois de plus mais ça me
paraît pas non plus complètement
déconnant après je me dis tiens est-ce
que je me dirais je vais acheter un
nouvel iPhone qui forcément coûtera plus
cher à cause de l'inflation est-ce que
je vais acheter un iphone 14 avec une
puce de liner pourquoi est-ce à ce
moment-là j'avais pas acheté un iphone
13 sur du reconditionné ou de l'occasion
vous voyez c'est aussi un problème au
niveau de la vente moi je sais pas il y
a un truc qui est pas logique on va
regarder ça d'autant plus que et je vous
en donne pas dans quelques instants
toute la partie photo au niveau de
l'iPhone 14 et l'iPhone 14 max ça serait
les mêmes capteurs qu'on a sur l'iPhone
13 donc si en plus on a le même
processeur quelle différence j'aurais un
iPhone 13 versus un iPhone 14 peut-être
un wifi 6e en plus mais est-ce que ça
suffit à venir changer je sais pas
convaincu donc bon voilà il y a toutes
ces trucs là qui viennent un peu poser
question donc j'en sais rien un autre
truc qui est intéressant et on le voit
ici c'est que potentiellement on
retrouverait un modèle de Qualcomm le
Snapdragon x65 alors celui-là il est
aussi pas mal vous allez voir notamment
pourquoi alors il serait gravé par tsnc
tsnc qui est le champion de la gravure
[Musique]
on aurait une batterie un peu plus
grosse au niveau des différents iPhone
pour venir augmenter un peu plus
l'autonomie alors la question qui se
pose c'est au niveau de l'usb-c Versus
Lightning l'Union européenne a voté au
mois de juin de cette année une
obligation pour tous les produits
électroniques qui vont venir se mettre
sur le marché européen pour 2024 d'avoir
de l'USB C c'est à dire un port commun
ça obligera à voir des blocs de charge
commun et ça évitera d'abord des blocs
de charge qu'on va venir acheter pour
type de modèle pour l'autre modèle ça te
permettra d'avoir des câbles identiques
bref d'avoir une norme au niveau de la
charge sauf que Apple derrière a dit non
mais c'est pas possible si on fait ça
chez nous ça veut dire poser un problème
d'innovation et on va plus pouvoir venir
innover correctement comme on le fait
aujourd'hui alors pendant longtemps
Apple à gagner de l'argent avec le port
Lightning qui était un port propriétaire
et encore avant ils avaient un autre
port dont j'ai complètement bouffé non
qui est également un port propriétaire
lorsque avant on n'est pas utilisé le
bluetooth mais qu'on se connecte
directement on avait des appareils made
for iPhone avec des connectiques soit
Lightning soit des anciens ports dont
j'ai une fois de plus bouffer le nom
donc là si tout le monde passe en usb-c
de toute façon aujourd'hui c'est du
Bluetooth donc la connexion on s'en fout
un petit peu mais Apple dit c'est pas le
bon truc parce que tous les
accessoiresistes qui fabriquent des
accessoires avec du port Lightning et
bien il verse des droits Apple il paye
Apple si aujourd'hui c'est de l'usb-c
ils perdront plus rien Apple ça fait des
rentrées d'argent en moins chez Apple et
Apple ça lui plaît pas énormément donc
bon il gueule un peu là-dessus sauf que
en fait cette loi et vous le voyez là
tout de suite sur le site de lequel je
suis ça sera appliqué dès 2024 donc dès
2024 tous les appareils électroniques y
compris l'iPhone devront utiliser de
l'USB donc c'est pas pour cette année
cette année on verra pas du SBC dans
l'iPhone 14 je vois pas l'intérêt je
pense qu'Apple va pousser au maximum
pour rester avec son Lightning et puis
couler tous ses stocks ça me parait
assez logique donc pas cette année mais
plus tard il est évident qu'on trouvera
de l'usb-c sur les iPhone est-ce que ça
sera partout au global peut-être est-ce
qu'ils le feront qu'on l'Europe je ne
pense pas je vois pas pourquoi est-ce
qu'on mettrait deux chaînes de
fabrication distinctes une pour l'Europe
et une pour le reste du monde vont venir
à mon avis tout normé et ça va venir
obliger à ce que Apple passe sur du full
usb-c à moins et ça c'est une autre
humeur qu'on enlève complètement de port
de recharge et qu'on se recharge
uniquement en sans fil je ne suis pas
convaincu non plus avoir et d'ailleurs
pour voir tout suivre de la cutech
abonnez-vous le petit bouton est juste
rouge si les rouges c'est que vous
n'êtes pas abonné et puis même si vous
êtes abonné pensez à venir actionner la
cloche pour être notifier dès qu'une
prochaine vidéo arrivera côté os en
surprise on aura iOS 16 qui a déjà été
présenté au mois de juin nouveautés
majeur au niveau de la caméra principale
des modèles professionnels on
retrouverait pas un capteur de 12
mégapixels parce que ici chez Apple on a
toujours le triptyque 12 12 12 30 angles
12 ultra grand-angle 12 et l'objectif 12
là on passerait sur un grand angle donc
la caméra principale en 48 mégapixels ça
permettrait d'utiliser la technologie de
pixel binning et devenir regrouper
plusieurs pixels pour avoir un plus gros
pixel et pour capter plus de lumière et
avoir de meilleures photos et notamment
en basse luminosité alors déjà
aujourd'hui ils sont très bons au niveau
des photos vous savez Apple ils ont un
truc c'est que les appareils sont pas
dire un peu [ __ ] mais ils sont très
bons partout pour pas avoir un objectif
qui soit meilleur qu'un autre tout
fonctionne bien tout est totalement
super bien optimisé comme ça vous avez
une expérience globale qui est linéaire
qui est bonne qui est juste ça marche
bien là on vient booster le capteur
principal sur le modèle professionnel on
viendrait booster effectivement et on
utilisait la technologie je vous parle
tout à l'heure de pixel binding de 4
pixels en un ça pourrait être assez
marrant ça en fait de venir améliorer le
capteur principal parce que comment
c'est vraiment à faire défaut par
rapport à d'autres modèles beaucoup de
smartphone quand les capteurs de 48 de
64 mais voir plus alors c'est pas
forcément le nombre de mégapixels qui a
vraiment faire la qualité il faut un
capteur de bonne qualité mais
aujourd'hui il restait que sur du 12
mégapixels à des iPhone qui coûte
jusqu'à un peu plus de 1800 euros bon ça
commençait à être un petit peu déconnant
tout en sachant qu'avec ce capteur de 48
mégapixels on pourrait venir faire de la
vidéo en 8k ça aussi ça pourrait être
quand même plutôt pas mal alors est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde va bien
faire de la vidéo en week-end non mais
surtout l'usage professionnel dont je
vous parlais parce que Apple a vraiment
fait un gros focus en disant on peut
utiliser son iPhone pour faire des
vidéos professionnelles clairement donc
en montant en qualité en œuvregré dedans
montant jusqu'en 8k ils vont venir aussi
chercher une nouvelle clientèle et dire
ok on est là on est en face des
smartphones Android qui déjà depuis
début 2021 je pense au niveau des
Samsung Galaxy S21 pouvez filmer en 8k
et Apple aujourd'hui a proposé toujours
pas donc bon quelque part ils viennent
un peu rattraper leur retard après
regarder la même composition comme je
vous le disais c'est à dire au niveau
des modèles non professionnels et bien
vous auriez uniquement deux capteurs
grand temps ultra grand-angle et dès que
vous arrivez sur le pro vente ultra
grand-angle téléobjectif tout en sachant
que cette année on aurait toujours pas
de zoom périscopique faudrait attendre
peut-être l'année prochaine peut-être
allez savoir et une caméra de selfie qui
sera améliorée on passe d'une ouverture
de f2.2 à l'ouverture à F 1.9 et un
meilleur capteur donc meilleur aussi
meilleures photos meilleur selfie bon ça
va aussi dans le sens de l'histoire
comme je vous le disais ça me paraît
très logique du wifi 6e on avait que du
wifi 6 sur les iPhones jusqu'à
aujourd'hui et quand même un peu de
retard il y a le wifi 6e ils auraient pu
déjà la voir et le mettre l'année
dernière alors peut-être qu'ils ont
préféré attendre ils ont dit bon
aujourd'hui on a pas trop de boxe il y
en a pas trop d'usage en wifi 6e on a vu
notamment en France pour parler que de
la France il y a différents opérateurs
qui ont lancé des box en wifi 6e
notamment ma bbox que j'ai ici sauf que
aujourd'hui avec mon iphone je ne peux
pas profiter du wifi 6e avec le nouvel
iPhone je pourrais en profiter si je
veux en profiter je me prends un Samsung
mais bon ça fait quand même râler pour
tous les possesseurs d'iPhone alors
autre truc qui est assez marrant c'est
vous savez il y a cette crise entre les
États-Unis et la Chine crise
grandissante on voit qu'il y a cette
problème aujourd'hui de blocs de
multilatéralisme on va pas rentrer dans
de la géopolitique mais avec d'un côté
la Russie et la Chine qui font un peu un
discours convergent sur certaines choses
mais pas forcément et les États-Unis de
l'autre côté donc il est évident
qu'aujourd'hui Apple doit commencer à
trouver d'autres solutions et pas mettre
toutes ses billes dans le même pays
alors autant Apple fabriqué déjà des
iPhone en Inde depuis quelques années
mais là ils vont augmenter accélérer
passer toute leur ligne d'iPhone
assemblées en tout cas en Inde alors
pour autant ils vont continuer à
travailler avec Foxconn qui est
taïwanais et qui pourtant fabrique c'est
produit à Shenzhen donc en Chine et ils
vont envoyer tout ça en Inde pour venir
assembler le matériel tout en sachant
qu'il y aurait a priori des fabrications
alors pas d'iPhone mais des fabrication
d'Apple Watch et de MacBook au Vietnam
ça pourrait arriver donc on voit
qu'effectivement et bien on va pas
retrouver uniquement que la Chine la
Chine pendant longtemps été leader et
très fort on voit qu'il y a quand même
une certaine redistribution et on va
chercher des solutions à droite à gauche
pour ne pas dépendre que d'un pays et on
l'a vu notamment avec le covid toutes
les problématiques de pénurie liées au
covid ça bloquait un pays ça a tout
bloqué la Chine aujourd'hui il y a
encore bloquée sur certains secteurs
c'est compliqué on le voit dans
automobile on voit également dans toute
l'électronique au niveau des smartphones
à cause des semis conducteurs donc bon
voilà cherche des solutions dernier
point et non des moindres on pourrait
retrouver une annonce le 7 septembre le
mercredi 7 septembre alors c'est vrai
qu'Apple a pas l'habitude de faire des
annonces les mercredis le 7 septembre
c'est très très tôt mais pour autant il
y a beaucoup de marques énormément de
marques avec qui je parle sur des
produits qui sont sortis de pas encore
sortis qui disent ok cette année on sort
beaucoup plus tôt les produits je pense
que à cause de la crise à cause de
l'inflation et à cause d'une période de
vente qui veulent rallonger un petit peu
pour essayer de tirer un petit peu la
sauce un peu plus loin ils viennent
sortir les produits un peu plus tôt et
ça pourrait être la même chose du côté
d'Apple qui annoncerait effectivement
potentiellement une fois de plus mais
des grandes guillemets le 7 septembre
donc très bientôt et des produits qu'on
pourrait commencer à avoir dispo à
partir du 16 septembre à voir une fois
de plus on met des pincettes on verra ça
voilà on voit que les choses bougent les
choses s'accélèrent en tout cas il y a
des trucs qui seraient intéressant sur
cette nouvelle iPhone sur ce nouvel
iPhone je sais pas s'il y a une
fonctionnalité vous qui vous
intéresserait plus qu'une autre un truc
sur lequel vous voudriez aller pour moi
il y a vraiment deux trucs extrêmement
majeurs il y a d'un côté la photo que le
capteur de 48 mégapixels et puis il y a
ce design qui serait quand même un peu
différent après il y a plein de petites
nouveautés le wifi 6 je l'attendais le
fait de venir avoir une meilleure puce
est-ce qu'on aurait deux puces ou pas
j'en sais rien et puis les prix surtout
les prix alors les prix bien évidemment
on va pas s'amuser à dire des prix parce
que il est évident que on est déjà pas
sûr de nous donc venir annoncer des prix
elle est comme ça alors hop ça me semble
compliqué par contre vu le contexte
actuel vu l'inflation vu les problèmes
de pénurie vu les problèmes de
semi-conducteur vu tous les problèmes ça
me semble assez logique que les tarifs
augmentent même si il y a certains sites
et notamment ici qui pensent qu'on
devrait retrouver un tarif maîtriser
alors pour le marché américain aux
alentours de 799 dollars moi je pense
que ça va augmenter je pense que ça va
augmenter entre 50 on va pas en euros
entre 50 à 100 € par produit plus mais
les grands guillemets mais tout augmente
donc j'imagine pas Apple hier ben nous
on va venir faire au même prix ou pose
propose au même prix et je pense même
qu'on pourrait se retrouver avec un
iPhone 14 pro Max qui aujourd'hui là sur
l'iPhone 13 pro max on est à 1800 et des
brouettes on devrait pas être loin des
2000 euros pas loin à voir on verra ça
bientôt on le verra bien évidemment
lorsque tout ça sera officiel on en
reparlera on les testera on les
regardera donc une fois de plus venez
vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà fait
et puis bien évidemment dites moi vous
qu'est-ce que vous attendez des nouveaux
iPhone qu'elles fonctionnalités je n'ai
pas annoncé là que je n'ai pas
potentiellement regardé avec vous mais
qui pourrait vous intéresser marquez de
moi juste en bas en commentaire comme ça
on vient alimenter le débat ça c'est
cool bon d'ici là prenez soin de vous je
vous embrasse moi je vais me prendre un
petit coup de flotte parce que il fait
une chaleur du fond et j'en peux plus
voilà je vous embrasse bisous à bientôt
Ciao
[Musique]